dieses video schockiert gerade menschen
in ganz deutschland es wird im netz
geteilt und dort auch heftig diskutiert
auf den bildern ist zu erkennen wie ein
polizist auf dem nacken eines
festgenommenen in düsseldorf kniete
erinnerungen werden wach an den tod von
george floyd in den usa
was die bilder aber nicht zeigen wie es
zu dieser szene gekommen ist was vorher
passiert ist und genau deswegen möchte
ich jetzt zu meinem kollegen nach
düsseldorf scheiden benjamin sack ist
mir nun von dort zugeschaltet guten
morgen benjamin wissen wir heute was
genau dort passiert ist damit es zu
diesen erschreckenden szenen gekommen
ist ja die polizei hat sich dem vorfall
angeschaut
wir wissen derzeit ich das am
samstagabend um 19 uhr 30
hier hinter mir in der altstadt multi
polizei zu einem restaurant gerufen dort
soll eine gruppe von zehn personen
randaliert haben
die polizei ist an eingeschritten und im
laufe dieses einsatzes kam ein
jugendlicher und hat den einsatz massiv
markt gestört und als ihm dann die
polizisten kontrollieren wollten seine
personalien aufnehmen wollten griff er
die beamten dann tätig an
und dann wurde er zu boden gebracht und
fixiert dabei entstanden die aufnahmen
jemanden jetzt weil twitter unter
anderem dann sehen kann
der clip der zuerst nur 15 sekunden lang
war ist insgesamt knapp 30 sekunden lang
man sieht aber nicht genau was da vorher
passiert ist und was danach passiert es
ist ein relativ kleiner ausschnitt
man kann auch nicht genau sagen wie
lange jetzt der polizist wirklich auf
dem nacken kopf rückenbereich dann drauf
geklebt hat beide waren das ja mehrere
minuten möglich dass es hier in
düsseldorf 30 sekunden ein bisschen
länger war das wird gerade noch alles
ermittelt aus neutralitätsgründen macht
das nicht die polizei düsseldorf sondern
das polizeipräsidium duisburg mit der
pressesprecherin habe ich heute morgen
noch telefoniert es gibt jetzt aktuell
noch keinen neuen stand
unklar ist noch ob der junge mann der
dann auf dem boden lag und in gewahrsam
genommen wurde
ob er verletzungen davon getragen hat
durch diese maßnahme ob die eltern
anzeige gegen die polizisten geschaltet
haben was die polizisten jetzt im
einzelnen zu dem vorfall sagen das ist
alles noch gegenstand der ermittlungen
das heißt die polizei düsseldorf hat
sich noch nicht dazu geäußert
die polizei düsseldorf hat gestern abend
eine pressemitteilung herausgegeben in
dem der vorfall so weit zu klären war
bis gestern abend erläutert wurde das
innenministerium nrw nimmt den vorfall
sehr ernst die polizei düsseldorf prüft
das video auch sehr eingehen und
intensiv und prüft ob ein verdacht eines
beamten deliktes vorliegt heisst ob die
einsatzkräfte sich nicht angemessen
verhalten haben